So now let me quickly summarize.
Basically, I dug a little bit deeper
into the whole concept of feature
detection, and we discussed the
different types of invariants, to scale,
to size, and to intensity and rotation.
Basically went through in detail to
the Harris Corner detector framework and
the SIFT detector, specifically
talking about issues with scale.
And also shared with you some example
demos of how we can make this work.
Again just for your reference there
are additional readings I encourage you
to look at them.
And also just spend a little bit of
time look at information on features.
The Open CV side this is one of
the harder areas in computer vision and
many people are writing specifically and
making it available on Open CV
to various applications of using
things like feature detection.
You'll get to play around with
this a little bit more and
again we'll be using this
approach extensively for
doing other things in
the next set of assignments.
Now we will actually move to a few
additional examples, like for
example, image warping, morphing,
high dynamic range imaging and
panoramic imaging, in the next module.